hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in chapters 10 11 and 15 of his treaties
on virtues and vices
alkawin is going to discuss three you
could say connected
cognitive volitional and also
action-oriented reaction manifesting
dispositions each of which could be
viewed
as a kind of virtue or as stemming from
a virtue and these are humility
compunction of heart and fear of god
fear of god is discussed a little bit
later in the text in chapter 15
humility and compunction are discussed
right next to each other in chapters 10
and 11 and
chapter 11 actually begins by
highlighting the connection between
humility and compunction of heart and i
thought it would be useful in
considering these to actually begin with
fear of god rather than with humility
and compunction of heart
because of the the contrast that we see
in them and he brings up a fear of god
or fear of the lord timor dominum domini
rather as the beginning of wisdom and
this is coming from the psalms
and he says it's a great caution
for sin always to fear god being present
he who fears god perfectly
diligently keeps himself from sins so
that that makes it sound like well fear
of god is like well you know the big
daddy up in the sky is watching me i
better be really careful so i don't get
myself in trouble
and you know admittedly for some people
that is indeed what it consists in but
alcohol thinks that that is you know far
too much of a punitive approach to
things there's more to this fear of god
it's not merely a negative comportment
of oh i gotta be scared all the time and
there's some positivity to it instead
before we look at that though
we should uh pay attention to one
important aspect of this
so fear of god
is fear of this divine being who you
know transcends not just us these
limited creatures we are but the entire
universe
and pays attention
not just to the things that we do
right to actions or operations to the
externals but to
the heart to our inward
comportment you know our wills our
intellects our habits what kind of
people we are and so he says he who
blushes to sin in the sight of people
how much more he ought to blush that is
feel shame to do iniquity in the sight
of god
they who fear god
with holy fear ask what sort of things
are actually pleasing to god and here is
where we get to a really important
distinction
there's more than one way to fear
and eloquent is going to use the same
term
throughout this he's going to use timor
and
timendi the gerundev and you know
timaray the verb he's using the same
language for all of these but he says
there's a really important distinction
here
are we going to fear god
like sons or children of god or are we
going to fear god in the way that slaves
fear a
master because these are indeed quite
different from each other so he says
slaves fear their master because of
torments
sons indeed fear their fathers because
of
love so if we are
sons or children of god let us fear him
from the sweetness of charity not the
bitterness of fear charity or love right
and we've got this contraposition of
sweetness one kind of taste bitterness
for the medievals they thought that
taste was on a spectrum with bitterness
on one side sweetness on the other and
all the other tastes
in between
and so
if we're going to fear god
in the way that is productive
i mean it might be productive for some
people to fear god as a servant as a
preliminary
step but ultimately you want to get to
the point where
fear really means love you fear to
disappoint the one who you
love the one who you care about
and so he goes on who says um you know
blessed is the person who's always
trembling and whose gift is to have the
fear of god always before his eyes he
who fears the lord withdraws from the
crooked way and directs his ways to the
path of virtue so it's not just
simply not breaking the rules it
requires cultivating the virtues the
fear of god repels sins and adds
virtues so
this is uh understood as an important
part of the moral life
when we go back to humility
in chapter 10
a very long chapter in the work by the
way
he says how great the virtue of true
verb humility may be easily learned from
the words of the lord who in order to
condemn the pride humility is opposed to
pride right
of the pharisees says everyone who
exalts himself will be humbled and he
who humbles himself will be
exalted and alcohol is going to give a
lot of examples of this drawn from
scripture
so there's a dynamic here right the
person who exalts himself through pride
is actually going to fall and we see
this in the chapters on pride
but the one who
lowers him or herself through humility
will be raised up they're not just going
to remain down there groveling in the
dust saying woe is me i'm nothing but a
worm no they'll actually be recognized
and brought up this is true humility not
fake humility not just having poor
self-esteem or something like that this
means you know recognizing the kind of
being that you are
you know something that
has a tendency to think of itself as
very special and awesome but oftentimes
is not such right
and he tells us that
this allows us
an approach
to god let us therefore learn humility
through which we will be able to
approach god just as he himself says in
the gospel
learn from me since i am mild and humble
of heart and you will find rest for your
souls now this is very interesting
because what this means is it doesn't
just allow us to approach god
god
himself incarnate as as jesus christ
is modeling and also teaching
humility so you know if it's good enough
for god to do presumably us you know
miserable bastards down here who are not
god we can be humble as well and we can
follow that great example
and so we see a lot of you know
scripture quotes here and he says
whoever will not be humble and quiet
can't have the grace of the holy spirit
live in him god was made humble for the
sake of our salvation so that humans
might be ashamed to be
proud so you know this is a lesson for
us
we could have figured that out on our
own but we often didn't and so he says
as much as the heart is inclined to the
depths with humility right so it lowers
itself
that much it profits in the height
for he who will be humble will be
exalted in glory so there's this promise
going on
and then he starts to get you know very
granular very prescriptive about this
and he talks about the first step
gradus of humility now this is what we
could think of as part of a progression
later authors will talk about humility
as being a mountain with seven steps
along the way different people will
construe this in different ways but
what's you know what's the first step
you can't do any of it without the first
step
so he says that
listening
humbly
to the
word of truth right that's very
important listening to the word of truth
by itself means you know taking in uh
teachings about how we ought to behave
how we ought to understand ourselves
doing so
humbly is already being
humble
being willing to actually have somebody
tell you how things are and not argue
with them all the time and then we have
to as he says
retain it
and retain it accurately not just retain
it with the parts that we liked or the
parts were comfortable with retain the
whole thing right even though it
makes us feel bad about ourselves and
that we're not you know where we'd like
to be but we have to retain it
accurately and then he says carry it out
without this
you don't really have humility humility
isn't just like
you know learning a few quotes and then
putting them on instagram and you know
then calling it a day you have to
actually practice
this sort of thing and you have to do it
as he says
voluntarily carry it out
choosing to do that that's difficult
right but that is what humility requires
and humility is one of the most
important virtues for alcuin why because
it is the one that is opposed to pride
also to vainglory you could say it's
also opposed to others as well
and it helps us resist these these you
know
capital vices that are likely to lead us
into all sorts of problems it also as we
see in chapter 11 leads to what we call
compunction of the heart
this is something that was very very
important
in
early and medieval christianity this
notion that your heart you know where
your your emotions are where your will
is seated
needs to actually
feel bad about the crappy things you've
done we can call them sins we can call
them vices we can call them evil deeds
you know and so compunction of the heart
as he says is born from the virtue of
humility so without humility
no compunction of the heart
unless you can actually
look at yourself
in an accurate light which is often
painful you cannot feel compunction of
the heart and compunction of the heart
is very important because there's an
entire
chain
of production of other
affects deeds virtues that is involved
here so he says
from compunction comes confession of
sins from confession comes penance from
true penance
not just any old penance will come
remission or forgiveness of sins so if
you want your sins forgiven you actually
need humility which then leads to
compunction then leads to confession
then leads to doing something you know
putting some skin in the game as they
say which then leads to forgiveness of
sins
and then he says
this is going to be painful
tears
are accustomed to flow from the twin
fountains of compunction what are those
twin fountains i mean you could say well
here's one one eyeball here's the other
but he actually also
names what these twin
uh fountains are and they're they're
within us so one of these he says
is when it considers diligently that is
not just you know
for a moment but it it deliberately does
this the merits uh
uh of of its work right when the
or when the mind diligently considers
the evils when it says ah wow i
haven't done what i ought to do and i've
done other things instead and then he
says the other when it longs for the
desire of eternal life now let's pause
on that for a second
because he doesn't say when it desires
eternal life and it doesn't have eternal
life oh i'm so sad because you know i
don't have it yet
he says when it longs for suspirate
the desire the zedirio
of eternal life
why does it long for a desire because it
doesn't have that desire
because the human being can say
man i should be desiring eternal life i
would be much better off if i if i had
my head on straight as we say and i was
desiring the things that i should but
i'm actually desiring all these other
things instead i wish that i
actually did desire the right things
well that can lead to you know
this
twin fountains of tears and
crying about these sort of things in the
middle ages was viewed as you know the
right thing to do it's an expression of
a properly ordered human being in
relation to being not properly ordered
entirely
and so he goes out and he says there's
four qualities of feelings by which
thought of the just is pricked by
salubrious loathing what is loading
hatred right uh salubrious means healthy
so there are ways in which we should
feel bad and you know even hate aspects
of ourselves and he says four qualities
of feeling affects iona so affects you
is this very broad um scope of what we
sometimes just call affectivity right
feelings emotions drives so one of these
is memory
memory of what memory of past deeds
if you remember your past deeds some of
them
probably you didn't measure up and you
could be like oh crap
i did that thing and i shouldn't have
done that thing i said that thing and i
shouldn't have said that thing or
i did a good thing but i didn't do it
for the right reason or i didn't go far
enough or i didn't follow through on it
so that's one
then he says the recollection of future
punishments
now recollection is recordazio right
bringing it back into the heart
and and sort of thinking about it where
am i going
and this could be you know am i going to
heaven or hell but it could also be
thinking about future punishments even
just you know in the relationships that
you have man i acted like a jerk and now
my relationship with so and so is
damaged and i'll they'll probably never
talk to me again right that could be
part of it consideration he talks about
consideration of our pilgrimage in the
misery of this life well that can make
you feel kind of uh unhappy as well and
then he says the desire of the heavenly
country does it desiderium right
uh so that he may be able to reach there
as soon as possible and he says since
these things are made in the heart of a
person right so that's it can be a
compunction of heart through these
feelings these affects ionis right
he says
it is then to be known that god through
his grace is present
in the human heart when you have these
things going on
then
god is present with you and he says
there's a desirable treasure
in the heart of humans the sweetness of
compunction the soul of a person which
is pricked in prayer profits to
salvation and when compunction is poured
out it's not to be doubted that the
presence of the holy spirit is present
in our hearts so humility and fear of
god lead to a recognition of our own
condition and what we ought to be doing
in order to
improve it and we have to face up to
who we are what we've done where we've
failed in order for that to happen
you